[Musique]
bonsoir jacques mersois d'être avec nous
on en parle souvent ces fameuses de
thèses qui s'affrontent donc qui croire
une bonne fois pour toutes sur cette
question de la pauvreté en france
l'insee ou de secours catholique mais je
pense que les deux ont raison mais parce
qu'il ne parle pas de la même chose
alors oui effectivement quand le
gouvernement dit le coach il en coûte à
protéger une grande partie des français
où il a incontestablement résoudre et on
peut le voir d'ailleurs en particulier
sur toute une série de deux salariés
mais quand le secours catholique dit
ceux qui n'ont pas été protégé par
justement cette espèce de parapluies du
quoi qu'il en coûte ont vu leur
situation se dégrader durant l'année du
coc vide et se dégrader encore
actuellement il a aussi
incontestablement raison alors on
commence avec les chiffres de l'insee
pour aller bien dans le détail que
distille alors ils disent que les gens
qui se situe à 60 % du seuil de pauvreté
il faut d'abord expliquer que ce qu'on
appelle 60 % du seuil de pauvreté c'est
un revenu net qui soit égal à 60% du
revenu médian pas du revenu moyen
autrement dit c'est 11 100 euros par
mois et bien ce chiffre est aujourd'hui
à peu près stable il avait monté en 2018
un petit peu redescendue mais disons
qu'il est resté stable en
2018 et 2019 bon donc ça c'est une c'est
une première chose après évidemment se
pose la question de savoir est ce que ce
chiffre est réellement pertinent mais ça
c'est un autre problème et ces pauvres
jacky sont ils alors les pauvres qui
sont concernés justement parle le
rapport qu'a fait le secours catholique
il faut voir que c'est plusieurs choses
1 d'abord il faut dire leur nombre le
secours catholique estime qu'il reçoit
aujourd'hui 7 millions je dis bien 7
millions de demandes de soi disant de
l'aide alimentaire si on reprend le
chiffre de l'insee il ya quand même
quelque chose qui est intéressant il
faut voir que et on le voit sur le sur
le graphique il faut voir que le suivant
les catégories c'est très différent
alors 40 % des chômeurs à peu près sont
dans cette catégorie mais il ya aussi
des 7%
des patrons de pme et ça cette fois des
indépendants et ça c'est important parce
que quand j'ai dit que la moyenne
nationale c'était à 14,6 pour cent on
voit que c'est plus important donc ça
prouve qu'il ya aussi ce qu'on appelle
les actifs pauvres si vous voulez les
gens qui sont actifs qui ont un emploi
mais qui sont pour et alors dernier
point qui est très important c'est
effectivement la part des enfants on se
rend compte que 1 enfant sur cinq en
france 20% des enfants sont dans des
familles qui sont considérés comme
pauvres et que dit le secours catholique
maintenant alors justement le secours
catholique insiste beaucoup sur le fait
qu' aujourd'hui alors ils aident à peu
près 7 à 8 millions de personnes il
aussi sur le fait que le revenu médian
des gens qu il n a baissé et se situe
aujourd'hui à un niveau très faible 540
euros contre 740 euros ce qui serait à
peu près la moyenne pour les gens qui
sont considérés comme très pauvre donc
ça c'est un premier point le deuxième
point est bien c'est que le nombre de
gens qui ont recours à l'aide
alimentaire a énormément augmenté et il
a continué d'augmenter l'année de
lakovic c'est pratiquement 7 millions de
personnes
troisième chose qui est aussi
extrêmement inquiétante c'est le fait
que un peu plus du quart de ces
personnes 1 27% et bien sont dans ce
qu'on appelle une grande insécurité
alimentaire alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire vous avez dire que
plusieurs fois par mois ils passent une
journée sans manger autrement dit on est
là en face de gens qui ont ce n'est pas
simplement qu'ils peuvent mal se nourrir
qu'ils ont besoin d aide que ce soit les
restos du coeur ou le secours catholique
pour améliorer le repas non ils ont faim
et 27% c'est quand même un chiffre très
important et le dernier point sur lequel
insiste le secours catholique c'est le
fait que dans les gens qui viennent
avoir accès si vous voulez à son aide
alimentaire il y a des gens qui ont un
salaire et qu'ils sont au dessus du
seuil de pauvreté pas beaucoup mais qui
sont un petit peu au dessus du seuil de
pauvreté sauf que ce sont des gens qui
ont de très grosses dépenses contraintes
alors que ce soit le loyer ça peut être
aussi l'endettement qui jouent le jeu et
donc ils n'ont plus assez d'argent pour
se nourrir donc il y à bien un problème
assez majeur de pauvreté même de grande
pauvreté en france alors on a beaucoup
parlé des étudiants justement dans cette
crise que dit le secours catholique
alors le secours catholique est aussi
très impressionné par le fait que les
demandes aide alimentaire ont été très
forte chez les jeunes dont les étudiants
évidemment plus 6% dans l'année 2020 et
on comprend tout à fait pourquoi parce
que c'était des jeunes qui faisait très
souvent ce qu'on appelle un petit boulot
alors ce petit boulot ce thème pour
était coursier vous ai travaillé dans
des restaurants dans des bars etc tout
ça ça a fermé si vous voulez tout le
secteur de l'événementiel qui était un
grand pourvoyeur justement de ces petits
boulots et bien ça à fermer et même
s'ils ont une petite bourse vient se
sont retrouvés avec quasiment rien et or
je dirais du filet de sécurité déployés
par l'état est ce à dire alors que le
quoi qu'il en coûte n'a pas marché dans
ce cas là je voulais c'est toujours la
même chose oui le quoi qu'il en coûte à
marcher pour les gens qui ont été
protégés sauf qu'il faut quand même à
rajouter là une chose le quoi qu'il en
coûte le le système en fait de chômage
partiel qui a été mis en place dans le
cadre de quoi qu'il en coûte
indemniser 84 % du montant du salaire
alors bon très bien quand vous avez un
salaire supérieur à 2000 euros nets dans
84% ça représente une perte mais c'est
pas grave quand vous êtes au smic et
quand justement vous allez finir le mois
ric rac voire légèrement à découvert est
bien perdre 16 % par rapport à un smic
ça peut être tout à fait dramatique
ajoutons une chose à cela le fait que
même si vous n'êtes pas touchés par ce
genre de problème vous pouvez avoir des
charges qui viennent s'ajouter à cela et
le fait que les cantines scolaires n'ont
pas fonctionné pendant une partie
c'était l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles le gouvernement a tenu
au
soul est à la rentrée 2020 que les
écoles restent ouverts le plus longtemps
possible parce que qu'est ce qui s'était
passé lors du premier confinement les
cantines scolaires ont été fermés et
donc
cette nourriture des enfants qui étaient
payés par là que par la collectivité ce
soit par l'état par les collectivités
régionales et c est bien elle est
revenue à la charge de famille qui
voyaient déjà leurs revenus se réduire
donc on comprend d'une certaine manière
quels sont les mécanismes de
l'appauvrissement des gens avec l'aco
vide est ce que on peut dire sur cette
question finalement que la pauvreté est
de retour
malheureusement oui malheureusement oui
et on voit bien prenons par exemple ce
qui se passe vous venez juste d'en
parler ce qui se passe dans les antilles
à la guadeloupe en martinique ce sont
des régions où nous avons plus de 30% de
la population qui est sous le seuil de
la pauvreté donc on voit bien qu'il ya
des régions où c'est extrêmement grave
et puis globalement oui c'est un
problème qui aujourd'hui se pose on voit
si on recense toutes les données qui
sont fournis par les différentes ong que
ce soit le secours populaire que ce soit
le secours catholique que ce soit aussi
d'ailleurs les restaurants du coeur qui
fournissent les données de ce coin dulac
et bien on voit qu'il y à une montée de
l'appauvrissement alors il ya une partie
de la population qui s'est assez bien
sorti de la crise de la queue vie vous
savez la france les français globalement
ils ont fait 165 milliards d' épargne
pendant cette année sauf que 30% de la
population on désépargner et c'est cette
population là qui a réellement souffert
de la crise de la queue vite c'est cette
population là que l'on retrouve dans
toutes les enquêtes qu'elle soit faite
par le secours populaire par le secours
catholique ou par les restos du coeur et
je pense que c'est une question qui va à
un moment ou à un autre
pénétrez dans la campagne présidentielle
et il faudra que tous les candidats y
compris le président candidat se
prononce à son sujet merci beaucoup et
on verra si ce sera le cas merci
beaucoup j'accepte fière d'avoir été
avec nous et je 10 à la semaine
prochaine merci